sie gilt als putins geliebte die
geheimnisvollste frau russlands
abgetaucht lange zeit versteckt wohl in
der schweiz jetzt aber zurück zurück in
moskau alina kabel war früher
kunstturnerin jetzt auf putins
propaganda bühne was für eine show legt
sie dort hinein glamour auftritt von
putins geliebter am abend wir zeigen
ihnen gleich aufzeichnungen für eine
tv-show es ist ihre show die schau der
dame die sich hier sehen die das alina
festival ja die ganze show soll dann am
tag des sieges im putin tv laufen die
propaganda show von putins geliebter
alina kabul war das hat sie am abend
dort gesagt
das thema krieg ist nicht nur ein thema
der vergangenheit diese feier ist nicht
nur für das ganze land es ist ein
feiertag für jede familie
jede familie hat eine kriegsgeschichte
das dürfen wir nicht vergessen
es zieht sich durch die generation
ja wer ist die schatten first lady
russlands wer ist diese frau das
besprechen wir jetzt mit unserem
chefreporter peter tiede warum hält
putin diese liebe hier sehen wir noch
mal bilder von ganz früher 30 jahre
altersunterschied zwischen den beiden
was steckt hinter dieser liebe diese
frau die ihn schon so viele jahre seines
lebens begleitet und jetzt für ihn die
propaganda show hin liegt peter tiede
unser chef vater bei uns im studio peter
diese liebe was weiß man über diese
liebe die ja hinter verschlossenen türen
stattfindet wenn man weiß nun dass ist
diese liebe geben sollte putin hat
zumindest nicht mehr dementiert er hat
sich immer nur darüber dass bp nicht
geäußert wenn danach gefragt worden ist
es gab in russland schon 2008 man das
gericht dass die beiden ja intim
miteinander sind wie man das so schön am
frühen morgen sagt und dass sie sogar
heiraten wollen die zeitung die das
gemeldet hat die wahl dann zwei wochen
später eingestampft
kommt nicht wie man es macht also kabul
war eine wirklich der vorzeige
turnerinnen die russland hatte
rhythmische sportgymnastik ist in
russland populär das ist das ding mit
keulen bällen und mit dieser strategie
man da und diesen mädchen auf der
turnmatte und die ist ja wirklich in
russland weltberühmt sag ich mal und war
auch wirklich eine der besten ihres
fachs und ja die gerüchte gibt es seit
2008 und seit 2006 war sehr gut aber
noch verheiratet mit seiner ersten frau
ludmilla da konnte er schlecht zu geben
dass er mit ihren verhältnis hat und
dass sie heiraten will die scheidung von
mueller erfolgte dann erst 2014 nato
vorgabe aber schon ein kind von ihm ist
alles nicht so schön und bitte nicht so
populär aber die liebe wird nicht
dementiert die liebe scheint da zu sein
sie
scheinen sich einigermaßen treu zu sein
die einzige frage ist und mit manchen
krieg zwischen der schweiz inzwischen
moskau jetzt kehrt sie also zurück auf
die bühne wir haben die bildergalerie
sehen und schauen noch mal rein in
diesen glamour auftritt also das ist
eine auszeichnung für eine tv-show die
ausgestrahlt werden soll am tag des
sieges wenn was in russland passiert
dann passiert das selten zufällig also
sie ist zurückkehrt salina kabel war in
der großen propagandashow putins warum
jetzt weil wladimir putin unterstützung
braucht also wir erinnern uns an seiner
letzten propaganda schon das wahlamt am
jahrestag der krim annexion durch nicky
stadion gestanden und musste kurz nach
außen sendet wären sogar im staats-tv
weil es dafür gab und karriere war macht
ein bisschen mehr her als wladimir putin
und man hat mir guten kann er seine
eigene siegesfeier dann im fernsehen
auch nicht selber promoten und da muss
man schon irgendetwas sind und ganz
klassisch und dann bleibt natürlich eine
frau am besten eine schöne frauen
populäre frau und hinter hier sehen wir
übrigens wenn man noch machen könnte man
hat vom aber hinter das sagt das klang
dieser tja und hat das ist eigentlich
doppelte botschaft es ist nämlich dass
das kriegs z dass wir von den panzern
kennen das auch die oppositionellen an
die tür bekommen in russland und es ist
doch dass z geformt aus dem georgsberg
wenn wir das nochmal sehen können es ja
auch an der bluse trägt ja ein schwarz
schwarz und orange das ist das geox band
das war das band das war das symbol für
die green besetzung das war der start
2014 der erste überfall auf die ukraine
dazu gab es das geox band das war an
allen autos daran es war populärer als
das z jetzt und deswegen formt man jetzt
das z aus diesem geox man da sieht man
es hinter ihr und auch an ihrer bude das
jetzt davor aber die 7 das z mit und das
schwarz und orange das ist das geox man
das georgs banken weit populärer als das
z deswegen macht man jetzt das zelt aus
dem georgsberg und das ist halt das
zeichen dafür für die annexion der krim
und des donners und kaffee war die hat
sich übrigens stark stark für es wird
gewitzelt in russland sie habe
offensichtlich die denselben schönheits
doc und dieser botox pole wladimir putin
der ja auch bis fast zur unkenntlichkeit
durchgeboxt auch vor karneval hat sich
jetzt verändert und sie ist halt
wirklich ja er braucht sie für die für
die propaganda und karriere war sondern
selbst wenn nicht seine geliebte ist
dann tauchen die wäre dann tauchten auch
die frage auf warum sie so unendlich
reich ist also nun betonen kann man das
geld das sie gemacht hat nicht haben da
kriegt man auch nicht die kosten her sie
ist chefin der oder im vorstand der
national media group das ist ein medien
kommt um rat mit produktionsstudios und
diesen durch partner von netflix zum
beispiel in russland da guckt man jetzt
natürlich schon hin bei diesem auftritt
wie wird das in russland wahrgenommen
also verbucht man dass da auch unter na
ja so ist es halt bei uns im staat oder
ist das was ist diese frau wirklich
beliebt klatscht man der ehrlich zu das
ist die gold card von russland also das
ist katarina witt russlands die ist ja
echt populären die mag man da und die
russin hatte putin nicht also haben wir
immer wieder dann erstaunt zur kenntnis
nehmen ist dass man mir putin ja bei den
meisten russen doch sehr populär ist und
kabine war hilft ihm noch mal noch
populärer zu sein und beliebt zu sein
und es ist ja für den großen führer der
beim kreml city bus nahm er gern den
großen starken mann und als großer
starker mann in seiner klassischen
männerwelt russland ja noch ist da kommt
es gut an wenn du dann noch als potent
gilt und eine jungen mitglied das 131
jahre altersunterschied und kabir war
und laut putin das ist schon ein paar
tassen menschen öffentlich das haut hin
man fragt sich danach wenn man sie sieht
warum wird sie eigentlich nicht
sanktioniert putins töchter also die von
denen man weiß nicht ihre kinder sondern
mit seiner ex-frau gegen die gibt es
sanktionen gegen alina jedoch nicht da
gibt es wilde spekulationen mit mir gibt
es dazu nicht es gibt die diskussion ob
man sie tatsächlich sanktionieren soll
es gibt in der schweiz eine bewegung die
dafür ist dass sie ausgewiesen wird oder
sanktioniert wird das sich irgendwo
leben gern von den tessinern ist es gibt
es gibt ein schwer bewacht ein schwer
bewachtes chalet in der schweiz
da liegt sie
bis ein bisschen einsam ich weiß dass
von einer um drei ecken gemeinsamen
freunden dass sie sehr sehr einsam war
dann die ganze zeit lang mich als mit
dem ersten kind das in der schweiz
kriegen muss was in russland ging das
nicht da war sie sehr sehr lange sehr
sehr einsam aber es sind ja noch kinder
hinterher gekommen also muss die
einsamkeit nicht von langer dauer
gewesen sein aber auch in den usa gibt
es diskussionen ob man sie funktionieren
sollte und das geht so als einer der
letzten schritte und wladimir putin
wirklich privat zu treffen aber
normalerweise müssen sie auf sanktionen
machen einfach sagt man sich doch also
das ist ein riesen fragezeichen warum
hat man das bisher nicht gemacht das
weiße haus ist das angesichts dieser
bilder jetzt noch einmal gefragt worden
und die sprecherin hat gesagt wir prüfen
das jetzt noch mal ist das zeigt es ist
bewegung drin zeigt aber auch mit man
hat das immer noch nicht gemacht ist
riesen jahr traut man sich da nicht ran
ist so einfach den namen aufschreiben ob
du kannst den namen einfach aufschreiben
aber sie hatte keine
entscheidungsbefugnis also das sind
tatsächlich eine privatperson die du
dann darum wie drauf hast du mir putin
über signalisiert dass weitere mediale
wirkung wie will natürlich jeder und die
propagandisten gehören mit auf die liste
drauf wie sie überhaupt nicht
verteidigen die frau gehört drauf und
zwar und zwar schon ganz lange mit die
propagandisten und damit die schlimmsten
die müssen drauf und sie wird er
fürstlich entlohnt ihre ganze familie
also der gesamte weibliche zwei der
kabine war fein familie mutter oma
schwester alle mit riesen grundstücken
von putins maklern versehen die haben
wirklich fette willen in sotschi in
moskau die haben riesen anwesend
auffällig ist dass sie anwesend immer
alle nicht weit von den anwesen von
buddy mir guten weg sind also natürlich
jetzt auch dann eine aggressivität
seitens putins wenn man dann auf diese
dame die so wichtig für ihn ist auch
privat sanktioniert peter tiede vielen
herzlichen